son psy crimes conjugaux ont été
perpétrés dans notre pays en 2020 et 90
victimes sont des femmes
mais dans ce gr une petite lueur
d'espoir en 2010 neuf cent quarante six
femmes ont été victimes de ces crimes
cette petite lueur d'espoir esquissé par
le ministre de la justice c'est la
baisse des crimes conjugaux envers les
femmes en 2020 en france mais en réalité
2020 fait figure d'exception et cette
baisse est un véritable trompe l'oeil
pourquoi réponse dans facture jetons
tout d'abord un oeil à cette courbe
voici l'évolution des crimes conjugaux
contre les femmes depuis 2006 année du
début des recensements par le
gouvernement en rouge les chiffres
officiels communiqués par le ministère
de la justice en bleu ceux du collectif
féminicide par compagnon ou est ce les
chiffres sont clairs il est vrai que si
l'on compare 2019 et 2020 on peut
constater 90 féminicide en 2020 contre
146 en 2019 année la plus meurtrière
dont le niveau est proche de celui
observé en 2006 2020 serait même la
première année depuis 2006 que le nombre
de femmes victimes de ces crimes ne
dépasse pas une centaine est ce que les
chiffres ne disent pas ce sont les
raisons de cette baisse elle pourrait
paraître encourageante mais la réalité
est tout autre
la première explication tient au fait
que beaucoup de séparation entre les
couples n'ont pas eu lieu lors du
premier confinement en 2020 on sait très
bien que la séparation est un facteur de
risque et que c'est au moment où les
victimes cherchent à partir que les
auteurs de violences et les agresseurs
commettre de nouvelles violences de
graves violences jusqu au féminicide
québec anciennement 10,1 possibilité de
partir et donc dû courir a sûrement
l'effet du bombe à retardement
la deuxième explication on comptait
stablement plus efficace pour faire
baisser le nombre de féminicide en
france c'est selon anne cécile bayle
faire présidente de la fondation les
femmes la meilleure réactivité des
forces de l'ordre la différence la plus
significative c'est plutôt le fait que
particulièrement pendant le premier
compliment il ya une mobilisation
absolument exemplaire des forces de
l'ordre
de la justice et des associations il ya
eu un travail main dans la main une
attention qui était porté là une
priorisation politique qui a été donné
unanimement saluée par les associations
il est vrai que les policiers ont
presque exclusivement puis se focaliser
sur les violences conjugales
le confinement strict ayant presque fait
disparaître tous les autres délits du
quotidien toutes ces démarches accélérée
qui ont appelé la police
elle réagissait les personnes s'est
déplacée sur place en cas de situations
violentes et puis au niveau de la
justice et les procédures étaient toutes
en stand-by sauf les procédures pour les
violences conjugales
preuve que les politiques de prévention
peuvent fonctionner dans d'autres pays
comme le mexique l'argentine ou le
brésil où elles sont inexistantes
les filles me sinon contraire augmenté
pendant le confinement depuis janvier
2021 toutefois en france les homicides
conjugaux envers les femmes repartent à
la hausse
en cause notamment le retour à
l'activité et à la vie dite normale
on revient sur une manière de faire un
peu comme avant où finalement c'est pas
tellement que les policiers ou les
gendarmes ne veulent pas mais c'est
aussi qu'ils ont d'autres priorités qui
leur sont données la vie reprend et donc
ils ont autre chose à faire
revenons-en aux chiffres ou 31 mai 2021
le collectif féminicide par compagnon ou
ex recensé 48 féminicide en 2021
si le collectif a parfois des chiffres
légèrement différents de ceux du
gouvernement
c'est car il inclut des crimes dont les
enquêtes policières sont parfois encore
en cours mais comparons le nombre de
féminicide à la même période ces
dernières années ou 31 mai 2016 on
comptait 45 féminicide ou 31 mai 2010 7
52 ou 31 mai 2018 49 au 31 mai 2010 9 60
au 31 mai 2000 20 39 et au 31 mai 2021
on peut clairement constater que les
chiffres de 2021 sont semblables aux
moyennes observées ces dernières années
en excluant 2020 année d'exception duo
confinement les féminicides en 2020 ont
baissé oui mais paradoxalement les
associations ont aussi remarqué une
hausse des violences intrafamiliales
durant les confinements on a une
augmentation de vent l'année 2020 de 70
% d'appels entrants et on voit que le
nombre d'appels continue à être
important même s'il est moindre
aujourd'hui il n'a été au printemps 2001
depuis début 2000 21 c'est aussi
l'exacerbation des violences qui a
fortement marqué l'actualité récente
comme en a témoigné la transe crime de
chahinez tout a brûlé vive en pleine rue
à mérignac une exacerbation des
violences qui s'explique sans doute par
le déconfinement progressif et avec donc
des individus
qui ayant été privée de liberté et qui
sont pour beaucoup déjà connu pour des
faits de violence à la base développent
un sentiment de toute puissance et
faisant fi de toutes les règles et m
absolument abominable ou plutôt d'une
violence assez rare
ce genre de crime n'est évidemment pas
nouveau mais la fréquence avec laquelle
ces violents féminicide s'enchaînent
devant témoins et inédite une semaine ne
passe sans que l'on ait un nouveau crime
conjugal qui se déroulent dans des
circonstances absolument dramatique
ce que les associations craignent aussi
une fois la crise sanitaire
définitivement derrière nous ce sont les
répercussions poste qu'ovide notamment
économiques alors que la précarité
touche de nombreuses femmes notamment
par exemple des personnes qui ne peuvent
pas quitter des relations violentes bien
qu'elles soient en danger parce qu'elles
ont perdu leur travail parce qu'elles
ont été forcées d'être enfin de partiel
et ses dires à être victimes de violence
est coincé à temps des relations d'une
vingtaine en ayant moins la possibilité
aussi de pouvoir quitter ses relations
d'autant plus que les effets du grenelle
des violences conjugales mis en place
fin 2010 9 sont en réalité très
compliqué à mesurer le grenelle c'est
presque immédiatement heurtée à la crise
sanitaire et 2020 a fait office de
parenthèse très particulière
ce qui est certain pour un de ses films
à le faire c'est que les appels au 39 19
la ligne d'écouté gratuite et anonyme ne
cesse d'augmenter en 2021 et les
chiffres restent alarmants
il faut aujourd'hui retrouver cet esprit
post grenelle où tout le monde s'était
bien mis sur les rails avec une culture
de la protection qui commençait à
émerger
on se remettre sérieusement à travailler
parce que sinon l'année 2021
malheureusement va être une année
particulièrement martifer pour les
femmes victimes de violence puisque tant
qu'on règle pas les problèmes
ils vont se répéter
[Musique]